vamos a verificar cómo es la mecánica
para el ajuste de los márgenes en el
mercado de contratos de futuros para
esto será importante considerar que
ambas partes tanto el vendedor como el
que compra son originalmente los que no
quieren estar susceptibles a la
volatilidad del precio de las manzanas
así que ambos pueden llegar al acuerdo
en vender o comprar a 20 centavos por
libra las manzanas pues viendo el lado
del agricultor que no quisiera quebrar o
salirse del negocio por tener que vender
las manzanas a 10 centavos la libra como
en el caso de la cadena de los país
tener que salirse del negocio por tener
que comprar las manzanas a 30 centavos
por libra o más altas y viene el
contrato original habíamos dicho que
tenía un precio de 200 dólares 200
dólares por mil libras así que
esencialmente serían a 20 centavos la
libra y como dijimos en un vídeo previo
el precio de entrega del contrato del
futuro cambia día a día hasta hay veces
que llega a estar más y más cerca del
precio de entrega actual o más bajo a lo
que voy con esto es que qué pasaría si
transfiriéramos dinero a la cuenta de
margen del comprador y a la cuenta de
margen del
pues como el precio de la fecha de
entrega en el contrato futuro bajará de
acuerdo al mercado entonces el precio de
entrega del mercado bajaría de los 200
dólares a los 190 e incluso hasta los
185 dólares lo que este chico está
logrando cada vez un mejor contrato para
el precio actual de la fecha de entrega
entonces para hacer las cosas justas se
tendrá que transferir el mismo monto en
miami la cantidad de dinero a la cuenta
de margen del vendedor ahora imaginemos
los dos escenarios digamos que
eventualmente en cuanto a nosotros
acordamos que la fecha de pactada será
el 15 de noviembre entonces el precio en
esta fecha estará enfocado en el precio
del mercado
entonces como puedes imaginar este
precio estaría alrededor de los 100
dólares como lo escrito hasta aquí abajo
entonces como puedes ver todo este
proceso afecta a los contratos de
futuros pone a cada uno en el mercado a
la baja por 100 dólares y ese día si en
verdad el vendedor quisiera vender
energía de vender las libras de manzanas
al comprador por solo 100 dólares diría
si ahí espera porque el vendedor querría
venderse a 10 centavos por libra las
manzanas si es a lo que temía o que ya
no está
por los cambios del precio en el mercado
pero esto es como una marca en el precio
del mercado porque el margen de
transferencia aquí como este precio de
entrega se fue a la baja de los 200
dólares a los 100 dólares esto sería una
transferencia para la cuenta de margen
de este chico que está por acá por 100
dólares por lo que en lugar de solo
obtener 100 dólares por esas mil libras
de manzanas también obtendrá los 100
dólares por ser el tenedor del contrato
así que su verdadero valor económico es
de 200 dólares sin importar lo que había
antes de su de sus mil libras de
manzanas o sus 20 centavos por libra
ahora puedes imaginarte el otro
escenario qué pasaría si el precio de
entrega ahora se va acercando a los 300
dólares que se fuera a la alza se podría
decir que los vendedores obtendrían un
bono o una especie de ganancia y estos
otros se saldrían los compradores puesto
que a ellos no les gustaría tener un
descenso en sus ganancias y ahora si
estudian las libras a 30 centavos por
cada una pues imagínate pero si al
recapitula y recuerda que si el precio
subía esto comenzaría a hacerse más y
más favorable
por el mecanismo de el margen área que
tuviera que transferir 100 dólares y es
lógico que esto iría a la cuenta del
comprador puesto que el precio subió e
inclusive si este chico tendría que
pagar hasta 300 dólares por libra porque
es ahí donde el precio del mercado
garantiza el término y él obtendría 100
dólares del vendedor por lo que
efectivamente solo tendría que pagar
entonces 200 dólares por lo que
finalmente ambas partes se vuelven
tendencias